لا أستطيع أن أتخيل
التأثير طويل المدى لهذه الصدمة
التي تسببنا بها لهذا
الجيل من الأطفال والتي
يصعب على البالغين التعامل معها كل
هذا الوباء ، تخيل كيف يشعر البالغ من العمر 14 عامًا
عندما بدأ العام الدراسي
الجديد  مايكل كان قد مر شهرًا ونصف الشهر فقط
عندما انتحر
كان ذلك في
بداية شهر أكتوبر وكان
متأخراً مثل 30 مهمة بالفعل
كنا نحاول
تحديد جدول زمني صغير له
أنه قد حصل على فترات راحة ويمكنه أن يأخذها
سهل لكنه كان صعبًا حقًا على نفسه ،
لم يكن لدي أي فكرة أنه استسلم
لأنه قام فعليًا
بمهمة منزلية في الليلة التي
سبقت وفاته
من وجهة نظر أحد الوالدين ، لا يمكنك
المساعدة في
الأسف ، أعني أنه لا يمكنك إلا التفكير
هناك شيء كان يمكنك فعله
عندما علمت أن شخصًا ما من
مدرستي مات من الانتحار ، جعلني
أدرك أنه يمكن أن يكون هناك أشخاص آخرون
يشعرون بنفس الطريقة
ولن يتحدثوا عن ذلك لأنه
لا يوجد شخص آخر شعرت به  بصفتي
المدرسة الوحيدة الفاشلة ، كنت
الوحيد الذي كان يسوء
أساتذتي منحني الكثير من
الفرص لتسليم العمل المفقود
ولم آخذهم
وأرغب في الانهيار في بعض الأحيان فقط أفكر في
كيف سأذهب  لكي أكون قادرًا على
الجلوس والانتباه
بعد فترة طويلة من الوباء ، أصبحت أقل
اجتماعية
وأكثر تركيزًا على نفسي
عندما يمرض جميع البالغين في منزلي ،
كان علي أن أصبح نوعًا من
الأم لأخي الصغير
العصير الذي
قمت بطهيه تأكد من
أنه كان وجبات على
الطاولة ، أعادني إلى وقت الاكتئاب ، لكنني
كنت حزينًا كثيرًا
كنت أقود السيارة إلى العمل وتلقيت رسالة
نصية ورأيتها لابني
، قال إنني لست سعيدًا
بشيء  يسير على ما يرام ،
أنا لا أحب أي شيء لا أحب
أي شخص
لا غضب تمامًا مثل
هذا هو السبب في أنني سأفعل هذا
، ثم توقفت فورًا
واتصلت بوالده
وأخبر والده أن يذهب للبحث عنه ولكن
في ذلك الوقت فات الأوان
[موسيقى]
كنا نعاني من أزمة في الصحة العقلية قبل
ر
إنه جائحة الآن ما تسميه أزمة عظمى أربعة ملايين ونصف طفل يحزنون على فقدان شخص قريب منهم ، هناك فقدان للعلاقات الاجتماعية الطبيعية لكونهم في المدرسة الروتينية ، يمكن أن يستمر طابع الخسارة والحزن لفترة طويلة الوقت بالنسبة للعديد من الأطفال لأنهم لم يتمكنوا من الوصول إلى خدمات الصحة العقلية لأننا في منتصف هذا الوباء ، إنه حزن غير معالج للغاية أيضًا خلال منتصف الوباء ، لقد توقفت عن العلاج لأن معالجي قد ابتعد ولم أفعل أريد أن أقوم بالعلاج عن بُعد ، لذا كان من الصعب بالنسبة لي الحصول على هذا الدعم العاطفي الذي شعرت أنني بحاجة إليه ، ثم في بعض الأحيان في الساعة الثالثة صباحًا ، كنت أبكي وأصرخ حتى لو كسرت ألواح الزجاج في محاولة لإطلاقها غضبي لأنني لم أرغب في إخراجه لأي شخص آخر ، الأشياء التي ساعدتني منذ الوباء للتعامل مع قلقي والتغلب عليه فقط هو التواجد حول أشخاص آخرين  تعجبني وبمجرد أن
بدأت العمل مع زملائي
في العمل
وأعلم أنه يجب علي الانفتاح عندما أكون
في العمل كما لو كان علي التحدث إلى الناس ،
فهذا يساعد كثيرًا
[الموسيقى]
لأنه يمكنني القيام بذلك  خارج العمل
الآن
[موسيقى]